two different foods that you've touched
on there which are often
demonized red meat no is it killing
everybody well again what's the dietary
pattern are you eating a ton of really
fatty Meats bacon butter is usually
thrown into that group even though it's
not a meat but it's commonly uh side of
a meat right uh tons of ribbe eyes and
are you susceptible you know what's your
body composition what's your exercise
look like uh are you consuming
sufficient fiber well let's say let's
say that someone is not a total Renegade
with this and they realize that they
shouldn't be eating super fatty cuts of
meat that they shouldn't be cooking it
in tons and tons of butter that they
shouldn't be having bags and bags and
bags of bacon there is a movement at the
moment guys like Brian Johnson who are
mtor activating the mtor pathway is a
nightmare I avoid meat red meat
specifically there is concerns from the
FDA there is concerns from all manner of
people who are experts in in some
circles with regards to diet that say
red meat is something that you should
have once a month at the absolute most
yeah
why what is it that you're seeing that
they're
not uh well you mentioned
um was the first one you mentioned oh
mtor stimulation
well that uh there's a difference
between acute and chronic inflammation
or mtor stimulation and the acute
inflammation or stimulation of mtor
doesn't seem to be a problem uh and that
would be the same of protein in general
wouldn't be specific to red meat any
protein would stimulate emor uh and the
problem that you get is is that as we
age we become uh anabolically resistant
at some point or less and less
anabolically
uh what would just
sensitive and a lot of people as they
age suffer from they don't eat enough
protein and they suffer from sarcopenia
and that can be a bigger problem for
mortality risk than consuming red meat
or any meat there you know for that
matter and I think uh if I'm citing the
right person I think Kevin Hall has done
a lot of research on that uh and is the
and opposes that theory that theory that
longevity Theory I think that comes a
little bit from Sinclair a little bit
from um wter Longo those folks uh you
know it's a lot of mouse studies you
have no human evidence no no human
outcome trials showing that that uh is
going to uh limit lifespan the problem
with a lot of that research is it's
usually uh influenced by the healthy
user bias people who tend to eat more
red meat tend to smoke more drink more
weigh more exercise less uh and they eat
all the things that are associated with
it you know the bacon double
cheeseburgers with the bun and the uh
soda pop and and the fries um and you
know and the dessert with that and maybe
a couple of beers that's obviously you
know they try and control for that in
some of the epidemiology it's imperfect
and they try and stratify the risk based
on other health
markers uh but for the most part again
as part of a healthy diet keeping your
you know watching your
ldls uh I guess the only other concern
would be cancer and that you mentioned
that World Health Organization you may
have mentioned uh anch I find it
interesting now we've got this uh this
big blowback on aspartame art came out
and said that aspartame was associated
with cancer risk what's your read on
that well my read is that they stud they
look at Mouse studies and uh with uh
huge Doses and uh it's not their job to
look at Doses and so what was the do do
you know what the relative how much a
human is it would I have had to have
consumed three and a half cases of Dr
Pepper it was something like 800 Cokes
or something a day yeah to get that
level of aspartame uh but the point of
that story is is that and none of the
the nut nurition phds which is the
people that I usually uh turn my ear
towards when things like this come out
none of them consider this to be a
concern uh we do have plenty of human
trials randomized control trials showing
evidence that when you replace sugar
sweetened beverages with diet sodas you
see weight loss and therefore improved
Health outcomes right just let's just
dig in this for one second this is
something that came up with a bunch of
different stories I've heard from you a
lot of the
time uh people will demonize the thing
which is seemingly less natural got a
name like aspartame instead of sugar but
what they don't realize is that the
weight loss from switching from sugar to
Aspartame is so significant that tons
and tons of Downstream benefits for
health come from that and it seems like
the concern from
aspartame has to be at dosages so insane
that you would essentially be hooked up
to an IV like like Warren Buffett's
nightmare yeah just pumping it into your
veins it's nothing for anybody to worry
about you had an interesting point there
when I I talk about um the importance of
of the overall dietary pattern and then
your general physical
health weight loss I I said this on a
podcast not too long ago and it was
clipped and thrown onto the internet
just a little clip of it and I said that
95% of health benefits are realize
strictly from weight loss itself
irrespective of diet and I referenced
the McDonald's diet we have multiple
studies now the McDonald's diet the
twinkie diet the 7-Eleven Diet where
when when people eat even a lot of quote
unquote crappy food junk food fast food
when they're able to maintain a calorie
deficit and lose weight they see
decreases in all of their biomarkers
they see lowered cholesterol lowered
blood sugar lowered blood blood pressure
and weight loss itself we know is
associated with decreased cancer risk so
that should be the primary goal weight
loss obviously those kinds of diets
longterm particularly if they're high
ins saturated fats and maybe your LDL
starts to go up eventually um
potentially if you're not exercising or
if you lose a significant amount of lean
muscle mass because you're not lifting
weights so there's a whole host of
problems at the end of that I said I
would never recommend a McDonald's diet
that gets clipped
out internet internet please leave that
bit in which we've touched on already is
satiety being the key of reason for that
is is that the best diet is the one
you'll follow uh and hunger is the
biggest reason why people uh will fail
on a diet why I keep going back to
satiety when you're looking at the
highly processed very calorie dense
foods that if you were to do the
McDonald's diet and it is possible to
lose weight on it I think it was 1,800
calories 1850 something like that you'd
be very hungry uh precisely because
think about how
dense those calories are think about how
little food you get for those 1,800 100
calories I mean what it's probably
a a medium meal maybe a large meal with
a Coke a full fat Coke would be it
wouldn't be a lot of food yep it'd be
like you say maybe a cheeseburger
probably I think he had to eat half of
this half of that to get through the
day yeah but nonetheless the point is uh
that the weight loss is the primary goal
and we see this with a lot of diets a
lot of diet tribes we see this with keto
and and my goal here isn't to on
anybody's diet plan there's many paths
to the same destination and I believe
they're all uh very individualistic and
and the the best path is the one that
seems the least restrictive so you can
adhere to it long term and and some
people like to lower their carbs some
people like to eliminate I guess we
should just say there's there's three
paths there's not many path there's
three paths to that to to dieting all of
them result in a calorie deficit one is
uh calorie restriction that's where
you're counting calories and you're
checking the labels on the and you're
weighing and measuring food and you're
using your little uh you know your your
computer or your phone to track your
calories that's that's one method of of
controlling calories uh the other one is
time
restriction uh and that's you're just
going to eat like with a 168 or maybe
that doesn't work for you you got to go
to an 186 or 24 until you just can't eat
enough calories in your window to to to
gain weight and you start losing weight
uh the other ones would be dietary
restrictions and that's where you start
eliminating foods that would be a keto
get rid of carbs that would be a vegan
get rid of meats that would be a Paleo
get rid of everything that was you know
created after 1960 or something like
that gravitar and everything that didn't
fall to the ground at its own accord
yeah so those are your options and you
pick one uh if you may or uh you know
find something that works or a
combination of the two the intermittent
fasting keto diet got became real
popular as a onew punch for a while uh
but how sustainable are they for you and
and different people have different
long-term results but the research shows
none of them are any better than the
other longterm this episode is brought
to you by levels one of the single
biggest predictors of how long you live
and how good you'll feel while living is
your metabolic Health the single best
way to work out how your daily decisions
are impacting your longevity and Your
vitality is by tracking your glucose
this is why I wear a continuous glucose
monitor from levels it allows me to
understand in real time how the foods
that I'm eating are impacting my health
and the way that I feel the levels app
interprets your glucose data and gives
you a score after each meal so that you
can see how different meals are
impacting you and it will give you
personalized diet recommendations that
are right for your body glucose is a
huge determinant of not only Your
vitality and your longevity but of the
way that you feel day-to-day using
levels means that you take the guesswork
out of this it can help you to nudge
your diet towards something which is
going to be better for you right now and
in the long term as well after using
levels I realized that if I have a large
carbal and I do not go for a walk
afterward my blood glucose goes through
the roof and I don't feel so good head
to levels. lmodern wisdom to take
advantage of an exclusive offer plus get
that 90-day moneyb guarantee that's
levels. link slod wisdom thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
clip with Stan then press here for the
ful length 2 and 1/2 hour podcast
episode go on press
it